Kim Kardashian shocked fans when she
shared that clip to tick tock piling on
some seriously heavy makeup for a wild
transformation that was really funny now
the mama four explains that she made the
video after losing a bet with her
daughter North having kids is just
there's no way to describe it but it's a
lot let's rewind on Wednesday the
reality star posted a video to The Tick
Tock account she shares with her
nine-year-old daughter pulling her hair
back into a top knot before drawing on
some thick eyebrows applying a whole lot
of foundation a ton of concealer bronzer
and blush all while lip syncing to Milly
B's Viral Song m to the B and
aggressively chewing gum welcome to the
beaches
oh and I forgot to mention the lip liner
I and false lashes yeah Bible it's a
great look fans were shook over the look
and weighed in on Twitter with one
writing quote this is the last thing I
thought Kim Kardashian would do on Tick
Tock Kim's response me too yep Kim went
on to explain that North was behind the
Bold look quote the bribes and bet
losing I have going on with North is
unreal you just gotta roll with it Kim
and north have created tons of viral
content since launching their joint Tick
Tock account in 2021 why not but turns
out they've actually been making tick
tocks in secret since 2020. North has a
private Tick Tock account she puts them
in drafts she's not allowed to post them
but we have lots of tick tocks since
going public it's been nothing but gem
after gem sometimes at Kim's expense
like that time North used the thin
eyebrow filter convincing her famous Mom
that she shaved her eyebrows
wake up Mia I'm awake
North this is not funny I don't know how
you're gonna top that and the mommy
daughter Duo have shared tons of
makeovers she loves a before and after
earlier this month Kim posted up with
North who used special effects makeup to
make her look a whole lot like her dad
Kanye West
[Music]
she really is into Beauty and she loves
a little bit of makeup her new favorite
thing ever is doing makeovers and no one
can see until the final look is done
clearly it's no secret that North loves
to get creative with makeup in fact back
in 2018 Kim told ET that her daughter
was already getting into her kkw beauty
products I actually had to put her on
our PR list and get her her own set of
makeup because she destroys all of mine
when she sees it and then I can't use it
for myself so she she definitely loves
makeup so whether she's doing an epic
makeover pranking her mom or winning
bets one thing is certain North is the
reigning queen of tick tock
[Music]
thank you